foreign
[Music]
often forgotten and never enough credit
roles and permissions are essential to
running data flow jobs yet can cause
issues when not set up properly today we
will walk through troubleshooting common
permission errors observed during
creation and execution of data flow jobs
in Google cloud data flow the permission
errors occur if the user or group does
not have the right identity and access
management or IIM role and permissions
configured and or the job pipeline is
not using the correct service account
before diving into troubleshooting
permission errors with cloud data flow
jobs let's look at service accounts and
IEM roles and permissions required to
run data flow jobs to run the pipeline
data flow uses two service accounts to
manage security and permissions data
flow service account is used by data
flow service during data flow job
creation and execution to check the
project quota and to create worker
instances on your behalf it will be
specific to your project worker service
account is used by worker instances to
access input and output resources after
you submit your job by default workers
use your Project's compute engine
default service account as the worker
service account
now let's cover IIM rules for data flow
roles are used to limit access for users
within a project or organization and
have better control on access to data
flow related resources data flow admin
is the minimum role required for
creating and managing data flow jobs in
addition it provides machine type and
storage bucket configuration access data
flow developer provides the permissions
necessary to execute and manipulate data
flow jobs data flow viewer provides
read-only access to all data for related
resources data flow worker provides the
permissions necessary for a worker
service account to execute work units
for a data flow Pipeline and finally
data flow service agent is used
exclusively by the data flow service
account it provides the service account
access to managed resources in your
Google Cloud project to run data flow
jobs today okay I will show you how to
troubleshoot and resolve some common
scenarios where data flow jobs fail with
permission errors
let's start with the first scenario data
flow job creation using Google Cloud CLI
fails with this error when you attempt
to create a data flow job using Cloud
console you will observe that the create
job from template button is disabled as
the error indicates it typically occurs
when the user or group is attempting to
create the data flow job with only
Weaver role or permissions to resolve
this issue add the data flow developer
role to the principle using the Google
Cloud CLI command shown here
remember if you are using Google Cloud
CLI to create the data flow job ensure
all the parameters are correctly
specified
let me now walk you through how to add
this role in Google Cloud console go to
the IIM and admin IIM page
select the currently authenticated user
account as the principal
it does not have the data flow developer
role hence the job was failing let's add
the data flow developer rule to the
principle
now let's go to data flow page there you
go create job from template is activated
click on it woohoo data flow job is
created successfully
here's one more scenario where data
workflow fails but the following error
during the verification of permissions
for controller service account to
troubleshoot this issue go to the logs
Explorer page
use this filter by replacing the data
flow job ID with your data flow job ID
that is failing and search if there are
any errors or Warnings
you can see the same error here
examining the error closely indicates
that it occurs due to lack of
permissions for roles slash data flow
dot worker in the controller service
account or the compute engine service
account which is used for executing the
data flow job note that this permissions
are available in data flow worker or
editor role this error will occur if
both the data flow worker and editor
role are either deleted or missing in
the default or custom compute engine
service account being used to resolve
this issue add the data flow worker or
editor role to the compute engine
service account using the Google Cloud
CLI command shown here for more
information about the data flow job
prerequisite IIM permissions and service
account check out the following
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]